hey y'all
movie retrospective time this was the
one that won the poll this week this is
1987's
horror thriller the stepfather yeah good
throwback flick
you had not seen this before had you
that was good
yeah i'm surprised it's weird because
it's one of those movies that
is like really really good and every now
and then like someone will bring it up
but it seems like it kind of slipped
under the radar like it has enough of a
cult
following that it spawned two sequels
and a remake in 2009 which you know i'll
probably talk a little bit about later
it has it has a good score it has a real
good edit
it's a fast-paced story it's got kind of
like
thriller slash slasher elements too it's
good
yeah so i feel like the guy okay so the
guy that directed this
joseph rubin um i think he went on later
to do kind of bigger movies like
sleeping with the enemy and stuff like
that
so i think what makes this movie so good
other than terry o'quinn who plays like
the main character
is because it was written by donald
westlake
who if you've never heard of him i've
read like a bunch of his short stories
and stuff but he's actually really
really well known or was because he
passed away but
um as like a crime and mystery writer
like so he wrote a lot of thrillers and
stuff
and he wrote the screenplay for this
after reading
about the very creepy and very weird
case which maybe we should do a show
about one of these days
of john list who was a dude
in the 1970s i think he worked as an
accountant it was in new jersey right i
think
it was like 1971 and he
lost his job he had like this big huge
mansion like that him and his family i
think they had three kids
and he was one of those real like
uptight he wore a suit all the time like
even when he was mowing the lawn and
[ __ ] like that and he was like super
religious and everything
and he ended up losing his job and
he was so ashamed that he lost his job
that he didn't tell his family and
eventually ended up
murdering all of them yeah and then
taking off
and they didn't find him for 18 years
something like that he was on america's
most wanted
yeah he was it was it was america's most
wanted like and i think they caught him
in 1989.
it was crazy because i saw like a little
bit of a thing about him today
and when he when his case was on
america's most wanted they were still
looking for this [ __ ]
um they had like a forensic artist like
do a sculpture of his face
and when they found him he looked
exactly
like that sculpture i mean it was
creepily
accurate if this movie one of the things
i liked about it a lot was you know
other than the edit and the pacing was
the score was kind of like a
like one of those new like a new retro
wave yeah
even though back then that was just what
the 80s score sounded like
it sounds like a new retro wave channel
and then uh
about the story and the tone of it kind
of reminded me of uh remember cape fear
yeah with uh what's his name robert de
niro yeah yeah yeah it kind of reminded
me of
kind of like a movie like that it's
about a girl yeah
step father that shows up he just killed
the
the family that he had before it's it's
a trip it's a trip
i think this movie it's interesting
because i think that the time period
that this movie came out
this came out in early 1987. i feel like
a lot of horror movies were more
slash i mean slasher was kind of the
thing that was in at the time right
yeah so i feel like they made it more
like a thriller
and then they kind of marketed it that
way but they didn't really get a lot of
interest so they started marketing it
more as a slasher but it's really not
it's it does have some gore in it and it
is about a serial killer
but it's more like based on his
psychology
and it's almost kind of like a family
drama except the dude's a serial killer
you know what i'm saying so it's so it's
much more like focused around
dread and around you knowing that he's a
serial killer but nobody else around him
knows
and you know that something bad's gonna
happen and you're just like trying to
you're kind of rooting for the
characters be like somebody needs to
figure out like
what the [ __ ] this motherfucker's deal
is like so you don't get murdered it's
almost kind of like
fatal attraction but to remember fatal
attraction yeah but with a guy
who's doing it kind of reminded me of
that it was from that same
era there were movies that were kind of
like this coming out
yeah but they were just kind of coming
and going you know i never saw this one
you know yeah like i said this one did
okay like at the box office it made like
two three million dollars um you know
because it didn't cost like a great deal
of money to make
they made it in canada mostly uh even
though it's supposed to be set in
seattle like in a suburb
but i feel like it did okay but it was
one of those movies that kind of
sort of got forgotten about but then
like i said it was successful enough to
get
a sequel they made a sequel in uh 1989
which actually has your girl meg foster
in it
okay yeah um and he and he was in it as
well even though spoiler alert uh you're
pretty sure he died at the end of this
one but it's like you know it's a horror
movie what are you gonna do
um they made a third one too which i've
heard is not very good
um but they had to replace uh terry
o'quinn because he didn't want to do the
third one i guess because they were
making it more like a straight up slide
or
i think what ended up with the third one
they were just like basically remaking
the plot of the first one and he's like
yeah i don't want anything to do with
that
you know what i mean yeah so um so that
there was that whole issue
but i mean i feel like you know nowadays
it's pretty common to do like a
psychological thriller
about a serial killer that's more
focused on
his psychology than it is about the gore
but i feel like in the 80s it was kind
of a new thing because i mean we just
talked about henry portrait of a serial
killer which only came out like a few
months before this yeah
and um so i feel like maybe those two
movies in particular
these two movies um are kind of like
almost like pointing toward a new yeah
genre
like a new subgenre i could put myself
back in those days and what
how i would have felt seeing that seeing
this movie for the first time back then
you know what i mean and it did it does
kind of fit the gestalt of the era but i
would have considered that to be like a
new
a new type of horror movie back in those
days yeah you look at it now they make a
lot of this [ __ ] nowadays
right but back then back then it was
kind of like the new wave of them
it was a good movie yeah good movie uh
there's something about it happening
back in 87 too that kind of adds to it
for me
if you had made this in the in the
modern day it's like the setting was in
the modern day it wouldn't have been it
wouldn't have been as impressive i don't
think
well i kind of heard that that's what
happened with the remake because they
did do a remake of this in 2009
i haven't seen it it's on hulu um but i
was watching a dude
like kind of talking uh at length about
like all of the movies like the first
one and like all the original
trilogy and the remake and he said that
while the remake is not awful he's like
it just it suffers a lot from those kind
of 2000s horror movies so they're just
kind of like generic
yeah you know it's just like a generic
scary thriller movie
and he's like another criticism that he
had um and he's like and this is
why it's instructive like to watch
because he's like i really like bad
remakes because
you can then you can watch them both
side by side and then you can figure out
what it was that worked about the
original that doesn't work about the new
one
and he said i think what's what doesn't
work about the new one is that it's not
very long but it's really like
overstuffed he's like there's too many
characters
there's too many um you know side plots
that don't really
you know they don't really feed into the
main plot
he's like if you think about the
original film basically he's like
basically there are three
plot threads and they all inform one
another
which he said which is obviously that's
like really good screenwriting
because you're not wasting a lot of time
it's a very like efficient
film um and everything even like
[ __ ] that's going on with the side
characters you know of which there are
not very many which he said is a very
wise decision
um because you have more time with the
characters they're more fleshed out
when you don't have as many of them he's
like but even when they're doing [ __ ] in
the side it
informs back into the main narrative
that being
terry o'quinn as the serial killer um
and
the family like you know the daughter
being suspicious of him
the mom not being suspicious of him and
also you have the
the side plot of the brother of the um
the woman that he killed previously like
coming and
trying to find the dude also but
everything is kind of like feeding back
into the main narrative which makes it a
very like i said a very efficient
because i think it's only
i think it's 89 minutes so it's like
very very short
there's something about it happening in
87 which makes the story a lot tighter
too because you're not dealing with any
kind of
cell phones or social media and it the
the story
in the movie itself is a little
self-contained universe which
yeah makes it tighter and it works
better
there's just if you try to tell this
story
in a modern context it just wouldn't be
the same
you just wouldn't i think yeah and i
feel like we feel as claustrophobic or
something
yeah because reality was a lot different
back then for any of you people that
weren't around in the 87 in 87
you know reality was very different
there's just there wasn't an internet
there wasn't
cell phones they're just everyone was
kind of like uh
low information you weren't stupid it's
just that
the world was a smaller place back then
yeah information was harder to come by
yeah
i mean because if you look at this movie
because basically
i i have to say that i think the opening
sequence of this movie
is one of my favorite horror movies
opening sequences from the 80s because
how [ __ ] great is that there's no
dialogue
there's no nothing it's only like it's
four or five minutes long
it's just terry o'quinn and he's kind of
like look he's kind of got longer hair
and a beard
he's like looking in the mirror you
think that he's just like getting ready
for work or whatever he's shaving and
whatever
and then he you know cuts his hair all
short he cuts his beard off he puts on a
suit and tie and he's like yeah look at
me
check me out and then like he goes into
the hall and he picks up
like a kid's toy that got left out in
the hallway then he slowly walks down
the stairs you see a bloody handprint
and then you see a whole [ __ ]
slaughtered family
including children in the living room
and he just
walks past it walks out the door and
walks down the street just like he's
a regular dude going to work and he's
just whistling camp town races
and it's like so it the first four or
five minutes of the film they've
established
that this is a scary [ __ ]
and also that you wouldn't know that he
was a scary [ __ ] because he
looks just like a normal person
yeah and see and that was kind of a more
plausible concept back in 87
a dude could kill his whole family and
change the way he looks and erase his
identity change his name man
just walk out of there and start a new
life yeah much harder to do nowadays
a lot harder facial recognition software
would find you
you know i mean they have weird ways of
finding you now
yeah and i well and and the thing too is
that
it's interesting because what what ends
up happening is like you see that
opening scene which is so great
and then it jumps ahead a year and he
has
you know moved to another town but not
that far away it's still like in the
seattle area and
he has found like another widow uh
you know that has a child basically what
he's trying to do and i think this is
one of the most fascinating things about
his character because he's very complex
um and he conveys a lot of it without
really talking
like he conveys a lot of it like with
his facial expressions and stuff
i like that they made him like his
motivation
i guess is that he wants the perfect
family
like on the 50s tv shows because they
show them at one point like watching mr
ed and being like all amused by it and
everything
um but it's like the thing about it is
that the realistic
you know realistic family life is never
going to live up to his ideal of it
and that makes him angry so it's like
then he just like snaps and feels like
well
you know my daughter you know the
teenage daughter in this uh who's played
by
jill shellin who was she was in popcorn
and
cutting class like later on she was
cutting class with some of brad pitt's
first movies
it was like a slasher and i think she
dated him for a little while like back
then if i'm remembering correctly
but um yeah so so the daughter's getting
uh in trouble because she
i mean her dad has just died like you
know a year previously and then mom
comes home with this dude
which you know obviously that's gonna
cause some tension anyway
but the daughter stephanie she
immediately was like this dude's phony
something's the matter with him
and so she's kind of the only one that
sees through his
[ __ ] or through you know him wanting
to have
this [ __ ] perfect you know
picture-perfect life picture-perfect
family
but him being a psychopath and not being
able to
do that so it's almost kind of like and
i like too
that they don't tell you at any point in
the movie
how often he's how many times he's done
this
because like they show him at the
beginning like killing that one family
and then he takes off and start and you
know you you're following this one
family uh
you know at this point and then you know
when he gets pissed
off with this current family and he's
gonna you know kill them and he's
you know made the decision you can see
him setting up for the next one like he
starts he quit his job but tells his
wife he's still going to work just like
john listed but then he goes to like
some other city
you know gets a job there you know
starts
wooing this you know widow that lives
next door so you can see that he has
like a routine
of like what he does when his current
family has disappointed him
and it's like so i so it's cool because
you're not really it's really scary
because you don't know how like
how many times he's done it before like
he could have done it like whole bunch
of the times
and you would know well yeah i think it
was only once
because of his age maybe the kids were
when he
did he killed him yeah maybe kids was
about 10.
but they weren't his kids they weren't
his kids okay well that but yeah because
that's what his whole thing was was he
wanted to insert himself
into an already existing family so he
would insert himself into a family where
he could catch that where the wife was
widowed or whether or whether dude had
left or something
i know he did that the second time but i
didn't catch that that he had done that
the first time
yeah yeah that's what he thought that
was actually his biology no no no
that's that was his whole thing he like
insinuated himself into an already
existing family
and then tried to kind of like take it
over so there was this like one
and and he was kind of like portrayed as
like the perfect psychopath because he
you could see that he badly wanted that
ideal like they show a scene of him
like watching some of his neighbors you
know like the the dad comes home and
like the
the wife and the kid are out there going
daddy daddy yay they're like all hugging
and kissing on him and stuff
and he's like watching it like kind of
wistfully
um it's interesting because i'm not sure
like how aware he is that he can't have
that because he's
a psychopath you know what i'm saying
because
he because everything about him is like
a veneer
and i think that one of the things that
really clues stephanie into
him being i mean she suspects that he's
that there's something that matter with
him even from the start because she
thinks he comes across as very fake
which he does um but most people i guess
wouldn't notice it
is that he gets upset but he's having
this barbecue or whatever
and then somebody shows him the
newspaper
uh article from his crime that he
committed like a year ago because the
brother
tried to get like you know he's like you
know they the cops have forgotten about
it you know
he gets a reporter friend to like insert
another article about it
like a year later so he gets like really
upset he goes into the house and he goes
down to the basement and starts like
just flipping his [ __ ] because he
doesn't know anybody's looking at him
so it's almost kind of like he has this
veneer but he can't keep it up so he has
to like go down in secret and just like
start hitting [ __ ] and like
he's like wigging out and he can't like
remember what
identity he is and stuff like that and
the and the daughter sees him
and is like oh see i knew that there was
something wrong with that [ __ ]
right there
and also i think one of the best um i
think one of the best scenes too is like
near the end
after pretty much i'm you know the
daughter like has figured out
that this dude he throws her off the
scent like a little while because she
tells her therapist that she's afraid of
him
so the therapist to his credit does
believe her
and is like well maybe something is the
matter with him maybe something's wrong
with this guy
so the therapist tries to set up um a
a meeting with him with him uh who's his
name is jerry blake in this iteration
and jerry keeps dodging it because
obviously he doesn't want like a
psychiatrist like looking at him
so uh eventually the the therapist
decides to like pull a little subterfuge
and say because jerry's a realtor and
he's like hey i'm
so and so i want to come buy a house
just so he can like talk to him
and uh yeah poor doctor ends up getting
killed
and so after that happens but but like i
said
prior to that um it seems like
stephanie had really suspected that he
might even be this killer that she read
about in the paper
just because you know because of the way
he acted and
she thought it was very strange that he
just like appeared kind of out of
nowhere like
not too long after that crime occurred
but
she and this is another thing that's
kind of going back to the old days like
before we had the internet she didn't
know what that dude looked like
so she had to write to the newspaper for
like a headshot
of the suspect right and
so what ends up happening is that jerry
finds the photo that the newspaper has
sent her through the actual mail
and he is able to switch the photo out
with another one
so then for a while she's like oh maybe
he's not the killer
but then you know like i said as it goes
on she does actually figure out
that he is actually the killer but mom
is
kind of clueless which i guess i don't
know i don't know how like believable
that is because it's believable
well it and i've heard that the sequels
get even more unbelievable
they're like straight up the women are
just like idiots it's just like the
the dudes are just like doing like
obviously like huge red flag behavior
yeah everything to do is get him
the dude was awful possessive of the
damn step-daughter you know what i mean
it looks like he was looks like he was
coming onto her a couple times right in
front of the mom mom didn't even [ __ ]
notice it that's what it seemed like to
me like like i get that
i found it like slightly unbelievable
but not that unbelievable but because i
could believe
that a woman who had just lost her
husband like only a year before
um and had a daughter to support she was
under a lot of stress
grief and everything like that and then
this dude comes along
who seems like a perfect guy it's like
oh i can fix stuff around the house and
he
like he wants to take care of me and
this and that and the other thing
so i can see her overlooking certain
things that may be in another if you
weren't in like such a desperate
or you know emotionally vulnerable
situation that you wouldn't overlook
so i can give it that but like i said
i've heard
um that the the the sequels
part two and part three they just made
the wives like straight up idiots like
it's like a plot device
like the dudes the dude was just doing
like obviously like psycho things and
they were just kind of like oh well
that's just what they do
you know what i mean that could help you
push the story along further and make it
more over the top you know that's that's
probably what they were doing
probably yeah because i do feel like as
it went on
i they they tried to kind of make it
more like a slasher but i like that it's
not like that
i mean it's about a serial killer there
is some gore in it but it's not
real over the top like you like the
doctor kind of gets beat to death with a
um
two by four it was yeah um and
the there's not really a lot of people
get killed in that i mean other than the
family at the beginning you don't see
that happen you just see the aftermath
which is actually pretty gnarly
um and i like that they leave the show
and i know this is gonna sound weird
but i like that they left the shot of
the dead kid like just laying there with
the teddy bear and she's all covered
with blood and [ __ ]
because normally they thought um
initially i think the producers were
like yeah you need to cut that out
because it's like a [ __ ] dead kid
that's not cool but they're like no
we're leaving that in there so they left
that in there and i'm glad they did
but um yeah so they they get killed the
doctor gets killed
and then uh near the end i love this
i love this the dude that is the brother
of the original
woman of the family that he killed at
the beginning he's been this whole movie
he's been like investigating like trying
to find out where the where this
[ __ ] went like they killed his
family he's like i know who the [ __ ] it
is and
and he figured out that he's like oh he
changes his identity so he might look
different but he can't be that far away
and so he starts looking for him and
does this investigation
and he gets he finds him and he gets to
the house at the end
and [ __ ] gets hallowrand he's
he spends the whole movie finding the
thing about that and he walks into the
house
and he immediately he tries to shoot the
dude yeah and his gun gets stuck in his
pocket or something like that and then
jerry's straight up stabs him right in
the stomach about that aspect of the
story
and i think you know what i mean you
know what i think i think when i was
watching it again last night because
i've seen this movie a couple times but
i hadn't seen it for a couple of years
at this point
uh because of when that happened i was
like oh [ __ ] i forgot he got halloween
and then the shot was like they showed
it like in a long shot from the top of
the stairs and then a close-up like that
and i was like i think that is a that is
a straight-up homage to the shining
right there
because that's how kubrick shot halloran
getting killed it was just kind of like
far away close up
you know what i mean so i think they did
that on purpose um
but i really kind of like some people
might be pissed off by that that jim
spent the whole movie and then like he
just walked in and he's like hey i found
you
that he gets stabbed and killed but i
kind of like that extra dude die
somehow i kind of like that because it
showed how much of a psycho that dude
was you know what i mean like
and i liked it in the shining movie too
because even though i love halloran as a
character and he didn't die in the book
but i like that because it showed that
even like all the effort that he put in
even though he had magic powers too and
everything like that that's how [ __ ]
crazy
jack was that he couldn't even like get
past it you know i mean like he couldn't
even get past the hotel that's how evil
that [ __ ] was
so i really really liked that so they
did that in this one and i'm pretty sure
that that was a straight-up homage to
the shining i'm not entirely sure
but i suspect it was but yeah so
at the end of this um you know finally
if it was me like if i was the daughter
and the whole time
like if my mom had like married some
creepo like that
and the whole time you're like trying to
tell her it's like hey he's a serial
killer
and like mom is like whatever you're
crazy and uh then it turned out to be
true oh my god i would never let my mom
let that [ __ ] down
so i don't so i don't know like because
the two of them were not in the sequels
like i said terry o'quinn was in the
second one
which is crazy because at the end of
this one spoiler alert
he gets shot a couple of times and
stabbed like
right in the heart pretty much does
stephanie stab him right in the heart
yeah yeah i guess so it looked like
right in the heart i'm sure i'm sure in
the second one they were just like
oh man if it had just been an inch over
it would have killed you or something
like that i'm sure they like have some
kind of thing where they say that in the
movie
but i don't know but as i said um all
three of these movies
stepfather one two and three are all on
to be
for free uh actually they might be on
somebody might have put them on youtube
for free too because i think i saw
somebody put one on
put at least the first one on youtube
and uh the remake if you're
curious to watch that i've heard it's
not great but you know
just in case you want to watch it uh
that's actually on hulu
so um yeah check it out if you haven't
seen it it's kind of one of the most
kind of a real underrated thriller from
the 80s
and kind of developed a cult following
like later on
uh but it's just one of those movies
i've honestly i think terry o'quinn
his performance in this like really
really elevates it like everybody's good
in it and it's just like a good story
and it's really creepy and i really
really like
the approach that they took um but i
think he really makes this movie a
classic because he's so [ __ ] good
in that role and i feel like he's
probably best known nowadays because he
was on he had a big part on uh
lost so i think that's maybe where most
people nowadays would know him from
but because i think he did a lot more tv
than he did movies
but he's just like [ __ ] perfect in
this like as a series he's so so creepy
and he's also i don't want to say that
he's
sympathetic um because i don't think
he's sympathetic he's creepy but
you understand why he's doing what he's
doing even though it's like a [ __ ] up
because he has like a really [ __ ] uh
just like john listed he had like a
really [ __ ] up ideal
of what family life should be lit and
everything had to be exactly perfect and
exactly the way he wanted it
and if one thing was like awry then it
just [ __ ] up everything and he's like
well i just have to like
kill everybody and start all over again
to see if i can get it right the second
time
so i like that they had that kind of
like motivation for him
but yeah so like i said all three of
them the original ones are on 2b if you
want to watch them
and the remake is on hulu if you want to
watch that for whatever reason i don't
know why you would
but yeah check it out if you haven't
seen it really good underrated thriller
from the 80s that not a lot of people
talk about
and i'm glad that this one was the one
that everybody voted for this week
because i had been wanting to do this
one for a while
so uh that'll do it for this movie
review we'll see you in the next one
bye
you